[Music]
from small lands in hotel meeting spaces
to the biggest stadiums in the world
these sports venues have evolved as
their audiences have grown and that
rings true with fan conventions which
have exploded in popularity both in
physical size and their place in the
cultural mainstream there is one place
one special weekend every year where the
two have been woven together layer by
layer for over a decade a combined
tournament of excited eSports fans and
convention of devoted followers of one
company can only be found at Blizzcon
this is its story
Blizzard Entertainment started as a
small company called silicon & synapse
in 1991 with the intent to make computer
games a modest beginning backed by
co-founder Mike Moore Himes grandmother
I borrowed $15,000 from my grandmother
$10,000 went into the company $5,000
went into my bank account and that's
pretty much what I lived off of for the
next two years it was a very small space
about 600 square feet and right out the
gate we started working on ports of
Amiga and Mac titles though the company
primarily worked on porting other
companies games until 1993 those early
years allowed them to define themselves
as a company first I think that sort of
the pre Warcraft orcs and humans era of
Blizzard really allowed us to grow the
talent pool at the company by 1994 the
company was renamed to Blizzard
Entertainment their first original
titles like rock and roll racing
The Lost Vikings and Blackthorne were
critically acclaimed but it wasn't until
the release of Warcraft orcs and humans
that Blizzard garnered a reputation in
the greater game development landscape
Warcraft 1 was such a hit that Blizzard
really became a known developer
everybody in the industry went Wow
became game of the year and that raised
a lot of eyebrows
the second year they weren't any longer
the new kid on the block
it wasn't that Blizzard invented or even
reinvented the real-time strategy genre
with Warcraft but as would become a
pattern for the company they managed to
put together an example of the genre
that captured the minds of their
audience Warcraft two and three would
iterate on that concept and grow the
fictional world of Azeroth all the
artists you know we played Warcraft 1
and Warcraft 2 but we had all these
questions about the world so we bugged
Chris so much he broke out these acrylic
paints we looked at him and we're like
what are you painting
and he painted a map of Azeroth on the
wall and it was his way of saying guys
this is the map of the world but
inspired by games like Ultima Online and
EverQuest there had always been an
impulse to give players a different
perspective to play from we kind of
envisioned one day we would want to
bring the universe of Warcraft to life
in sort of a persistent universe game
that you could be an individual
character within this living breathing
world released in 2004 ruled of Warcraft
was the result of a rapidly growing
development team putting in years worth
of over time to bring Azeroth to life in
a way that fans of the Warcraft series
had yet to experience by the end of the
project we had 60 people on the team and
we took us 5 years to make like Warcraft
orcs in humans Wow was not the first
massively multiplayer online
role-playing game but it would go on to
be the biggest I think it shocked and
surprised people it changed the way
people thought of things that changed
the social aspects of gaming and took it
to an entirely different level we had
planned to have a million users within
the first 12 months of the game we had
those first million users within like
three or four months it was truly
amazing is how big a success it became I
think that caught everyone off guard
that release and the massive cultural
phenomenon it became were the reason
that Blizzcon could happen at all
Blizzard had always had a following born
from their popular titles in Warcraft
Diablo and Starcraft but it was Wow
success that catapulted the company to
the forefront of PC gaming I had one of
those moments I think everybody had one
of those moments like oh now we've made
it and that was bliss con it's important
to remember that at the time of Wow's
release the gaming landscape was very
different from what it is today
RTS games were usually 1v1 or 2v2 FPS
games typically had a maximum of 32
players in a server at once and a
majority of gamers were used to a
single-player experience unlike their
other titles while encourage players to
seek out allies and those allies often
became friends outside of the game after
all at release you needed 40 players
online all at once to complete the
hardest content that Wow had to offer
Wow fans don't mess around I mean they
take World of Warcraft seriously how
many of you have played World of
Warcraft
and Blizzcon gave those communities a
place to meet each other face to face
often for the first time this is these
people's lives I mean they even some of
these people came from all over the
country all over the world to come
together to meet some of these players
that they've met in the game and in 2007
Blizzard made one of the biggest
announcements in was history Oh
[Music]
Wow wrath of the lich king expansion
brought back fan-favorite Warcraft 3
character Arthas and would go on to
represent the absolute peak of the
game's popularity and cultural relevance
as near expansions end the game averaged
about 11 and a half million subscribers
there must always be even today
Wow announcements continue to be a
mainstay and blaze Khan's opening
ceremony has played host to some of the
game's biggest reveals I am pleased and
also a little bit nervous to announce
the development of a classic server
option for World of Warcraft and most
exciting cinematics ours is a cycle of
hatred alliances forged and broken
when you paid the price for sharing this
world and we have forgotten what makes
us strong whether as a source for
updates on the future of the game or a
place to meet friends in new and old
world of warcraft remains a pillar of
Blizzcon
that inaugural Blizzcon in 2005 featured
eight thousand attendees a bevy of fan
events previews of upcoming content and
a closing concert by The Offspring
I had no idea that one day I would be
standing up here welcoming almost 8,000
people to our very first Blizzcon it was
not televised and there was no live
viewing option outside of physically
being at the Convention Center in
Anaheim California this is an
opportunity for you to meet our
developers and speak with them to learn
a little bit about how they perform
their craft and about how Blizzard goes
about making games and even though this
initial Blizzcon was considered a
success it still wasn't clear that the
event should be an annual one thank you
again for coming and welcome to Blizzcon
although Blizzard chose not to halt
Blizzcon in 2006 2007 saw the convention
grow to over 13,000 attendees while 2008
introduced a new way to enjoyable as
cond as a pay-per-view event on DirecTV
its Blizzcon live on DirecTV while
Blizzcon was making strides Blizzard was
bringing another of their popular titles
back and this time trying to do justice
to the competitive community that had
sprung up behind it it's about time
while Blizzcon itself may never have
existed without world of warcraft the
tournament aspect of the convention
would become invariably entwined with
another game a game that had
simultaneously been reshaping
competitive video gaming
initially released in 1998 and then
adding the broodwar expansion later that
same year
Starcraft had been well-received
worldwide as a worthy successor to
blizzards RTS legacy my first exposure
to Starcraft was actually in 1999 we
didn't know what this was it was
something totally new it was that game
that was kind of like Warcraft just
let's play it but it was new it was
different and it was fun but the game
truly became something else in South
Korea where it exploded into a vibrant
competitive scene all sans or Co was out
in Korea and it came back with pictures
of people dressing up like hydrolysed
and Protoss units and Terran units and
suddenly it was on a whole nother level
Starcraft saw the rise of major
sponsorships and televised games as it
built much of the structure that would
go on to define Korean eSports when the
original Starcraft was made it was
designed to be a great game but it
wasn't necessarily designed specifically
to be an eSport that was something the
community showed us but it could be how
it could be done they made that happen
Blizzcon 2005 had featured official
Blizzard Invitational tournaments for
Warcraft 3 the Frozen Throne and
StarCraft brood war while they were
small compared to what Starcraft had
seen in Korea and were Invitational
tournaments they were also there at the
very beginning reach is gonna grab
second place and yellow is your Grand
Champion folks let's hear it come on
development on a Starcraft sequel had
begun in 2003 a year later than planned
after resources had been diverted to the
development of WoW but after thousands
of builds and just months before
Blizzcon 2007 Blizzard announced the
release of Starcraft 2
it is my honor to present to you
blizzards newest game Starcraft 2 which
would ultimately be split into three
separate games would release the first
chapter wings of Liberty in July 2010
but the eSports community did not
immediately shift to the new title with
many Korean pros opting to continue
playing brood war zerrin adds your World
Cyber Games grand final 2010 handling
for the 10th anniversary is first time
in world cyber games PLAs taking it home
but Blizzcon 2010 hosted an invitational
tournament for starcraft 2 and while
there was a show match for that game
between boxer and fruit dealer it
appeared like the community might remain
split and with the removal of land
functionality some players of the
original Starcraft caused an uproar but
since that time Starcraft 2 has seen
incredible competitive moments is
Oh
and even a post-2015 resurgence of sorts
it's share of setbacks as a number of
StarCraft II pro players and their coach
have been arrested for match-fixing in
Korea whatever your opinion on StarCraft
II sports today it is a wandering RTS
dragon the last of its kind and at
Blizzcon it represented the beginning of
the events massive eSports growth
[Music]
getting tickets for Blizzcon in 2008 had
been a nightmare and by 2009 it was
clear that the convention needed even
more space and more ways for fans to
experience it with a release of wrath of
the lich king why was at the height of
its popularity and both Starcraft and
Diablo son released sequels were
generating hype the growth and
complexity and scale of the games were
making that has been outpaced
by the number of people around the world
that are interested in playing our games
the convention expanded to four halls
allowing even more tickets to be sold
but for the first time fans could watch
online with a virtual ticket that they
could purchase this is Blizzcon 2009 in
Anaheim California the biggest gaming
company in the world Blizzard is putting
on a huge celebration for their fans it
wasn't quite like being at the event
itself but fans no longer needed to
scrape together details on their
favorite games Diablo 3
Starcraft 2 it's a bow tab and World of
Warcraft
2010's Starcraft tournament whet the
appetite of fans who in 2011 packed the
hall to watch an exhilarating final
series between Nestea and MVP but
Blizzcon didn't happen in 2012 instead
there was a battlenet World Championship
Tournament where the Starcraft 2 and Wow
arena tournaments were held it was
eSports but it wasn't Blizzcon what
Blizzard fans did get in 2012 was the
highly anticipated sequel to the Diablo
series
[Music]
Diablo had always been blizzards darkest
franchise featuring a gothic aesthetic
and a touch of diabolic terror that drew
the player into the action RPG gameplay
since the dawn of time of a Pecha war
called the eternal conflict has raged
between the hosts of the high heavens
and the legions of the burning hell's
1996 is Diablo the first game in the
series quickly became a fan favorite and
sequel Diablo 2 released only four years
later in 2000 Chevy saved as usual
Blizzard did not invent the a RPG genre
but they honed it into an addictive and
accessible package but if you were a
Diablo fan when Diablo 3 was announced
in 2008 you had a long time to wait for
agonizing years of updates as the game
continued development our goal is to get
it out by the end of 2011 right now
we're in spring we're right around our
second alpha and pushing towards an
internal beta when it released on PC and
Mac in May 2012 the lack of an offline
single-player mode caused controversy
this was only heightened as the dreaded
error 37 prevented players from properly
connecting to the game's authentication
server the game while not maligned felt
like a less punitive Diablo 2 adding
little to the genre the 2014 expansion
Reaper of souls did quite a bit to
change that perception and the addition
of ranked seasons gave players a reason
to push their characters and skills
harder than ever before
when Blizzcon returned in 2013 it was
clear that the event like Blizzard
Entertainment itself was going through
massive changes Blizzard dota this the
inspiration for this map goes all the
way back actually to the original
Starcraft perhaps you guys have heard of
a map called the Aeon of strife this is
the map that really started everything
the rise of what we now call MOBAs had
not gone unnoticed to Blizzard the
original defense of the ancients had
after all been a mod for Warcraft 3 at
the time of its announcement in 2010
Blizzard dota was actually just a
modification for Starcraft 2 but
Blizzard was not the only developer
angling for that audience valve had
announced the development of dota 2 less
than a month before Blizzcon
while Riot Games as League of Legends
had been released only a year prior by
2013 Blizzard dota had become heroes of
the storm and blizzards take on MOBAs
even if they refuse to call it that had
a playable alpha at Blizzcon and of
course for us it's about paying homage
to the amazing Blizzard community that
really helped create and invent this
entire genre of game well the game has
yet to achieve the heights of popularity
of its peers in the genre it truly went
for a different niche less focus on
individual power spikes and more on team
play it also managed something that
blizzards fans had wanted to see for
some time to combine the characters of
the various franchises the company owned
into one highly marketable package so
heroes of the storm is a game that has
evolved over many many years and it's
actually a story of Blizzcon and our
evolution from one Blizzcon to the next
as Blizzcon plowed forward hots would
also become an eSports mainstay hosting
some of the most exciting matches to
ever be played at the competitive level
has done the unexpected
[Applause]
another new game was also on the horizon
hearthstone heroes of war hearthstone
would be blizzards first foray into
online collectible card games and in
2013 the game was announced at pax while
its beta period was revealed at Blizzcon
hearthstone it's a collectible card game
the releases this year and you guys can
play on the show floor today again card
games had existed before hearthstone the
twist make it easy to start fast to play
entrench it in Warcraft lore and give it
depth at the upper end and of course a
little bit of RNG malygos this is gonna
blow
I'm sorry I love the Walther oh look at
oh my god
Blizzcon 2013 featured an invitational
hearthstone tournament and by 2014 it
had its first legitimate World
Championship at Blizzcon while hots had
its first Invitational this was in
addition to the Starcraft 2 and Wow
tournaments by 2015 there were no
Invitational tournaments and all four
games were hosting their own World
Championships as part of Blizzcon
God
[Applause]
but that growing eSports presence was
overshadowed by the 2014 announcement of
yet another new Blizzard project one
that unbeknownst to fans at the time
would become monumental in building the
foundation for blizzards future
commitment to eSports so my friends get
a load of this we hope you love it like
we do I'll see on the other side
in 2014 the world got its first look at
overwatch an elite international task
force charged with ending the war and
restoring Liberty to all nations
overwatch born from the ashes of
canceled blizzard project Titan
overwatch was the company's first new
intellectual property in 17 years and in
so many ways overwatch is from from its
themes to its gameplay like everything
about this project whether that's
visible to the end-user or not is our
story
the class-based team shooter immediately
drew comparisons to Valve's Team
Fortress 2 and in many cases pro players
from that game made the jump but the
game did two things incredibly well it
not only managed to expand on that type
of gameplay but it brought in players
who would never have considered the
genre otherwise I think it's going to
just get bigger and bigger as time goes
on because it seems to be the new FPS
style I mean I wouldn't even consider
that PS it's way more than that after a
protracted beta period that was
sardonically nicknamed only watch by
hungry fans the game released in May
2016 sales soared as the game hit over
10 million players by June and exceeded
1 billion dollars in revenue by quarter
1 2017 but before the iron had cooled
Blizzard dropped another bombshell at
Blizzcon 2016 the tenth Blizzcon they
announced the creation of over watched
a fully franchised eSports league with
localized teams we're looking for the
top players in the world and the team
owners who will form the overwatch
league while Blizzard had been slow to
grasp Starcraft eSports and had been
criticized for its handling of early
Starcraft 2 here with overwatch they
would aim to grab hold of the
competitive scene immediately and like
the game this league seemed to have the
potential to bring in fans who had
otherwise the little or no interest in
the popular games of the time come to
the Blizzard arena the wait is finally
over it's time to kick off the inaugural
season of the overwatch League but so
far actual league play has yet to make
an appearance at the con instead
national teams compete in the overwatch
World Cup
whatever the games eSports future at
Blizzcon the game and League represent a
big investment from Blizzard into their
company and conventions future the
Anaheim Convention Center which has
always hosted Blizzcon is now regularly
packed the halls are filled with both
fan events and eSports competitions but
however Blizzard handles eSports moving
forward that unique blend of fans is
unlikely to go away how many of you have
played World of Warcraft with the
successful initial season of overwatch
League a resurgent World of Warcraft and
a Diablo announcement extremely likely
Blizzcon 2018 will bring fans out of the
woodwork yet again and as long as
Blizzard fans are hungry for more there
will be a place every year for them to
find it thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]